hi Ron welcome to the closing webinar of
the imaging science series so we're
about to get started
and we have lots of cool images from
researchers to show you and the ones
that you all have sent in as well so
just scroll through a selection of those
I mean with that I'm gonna hand this
over to you Erika Reinfeld who's going
to start us off thank you so much Brian
all right we are so excited to be here
with you so two weeks ago we hosted the
opening webinar I am actually not
looking at the poll so I don't know how
many of you attended it if you didn't I
hope you'll log on to the museum site
and check it out
we had we hosted that with two fabulous
photographers Keith Allen bogan and
Felice Frankel and we are really excited
to close this week out with the research
counterpart to that so our researchers
our guests researchers will be sharing a
couple of their own science photographs
with you images that came out of active
research here at MIT and then they'll be
talking to you about some of the images
that they saw on this two-week
exploration that they found really
intriguing Before we jump into their
presentations I did want to call out a
couple of the op' of the themes from the
opening webinar by contact for context
for this conversation so one of the
central ideas that we talked about was
the idea of photography and imaging as a
tool of science helping us to make
observations and to communicate
scientific ideas as science
photographers both Keith and Felice
noticed science everywhere but I thought
it was really interesting Keith
identifies as an artist Felice does not
and so they both talked about the
intentionality of a good science
photograph and that it the important
element of that is being intentional
about your photography but also leaving
yourself open to discovery and I think
that's very characteristic of a lot of
the images we're going to be looking at
today one of the comments that came
through in the chat that I really liked
was that many of the photographs that we
saw were in some ways unintentional art
they weren't designed to be art but they
still had an artistic component to it it
was a combination of the inspect the
expected and the unexpected that come
together to tell the story we also
talked a little bit about maintaining
the scientific integrity of a photograph
of the scientific subject when taking a
photograph but then still using the
photograph to tell a story and then
finally we talked a little bit about the
value of bringing both people and ideas
together to create a photograph and make
sense of what's being represented in the
world so in that spirit we're gonna
bring in our guests and as they present
their images you are welcome to use the
Q&A feature down at the bottom of your
screen to address questions either to an
individual or to the whole group and
we'll try to get to at least a handful
of those after everyone has presented
their image so we're gonna start with
Serena Kumari who is a researcher at the
Koch Institute where I work you can see
the public galleries behind me this is
our annual image awards exhibition of
biomechanical images and I actually used
Suda's winning image from the Image
Awards often to represent the image the
image Awards competition as a whole and
just as an example of a scientific
photograph so I'll stop talking and let
sudha tell you and show you more
hi everyone so I am Sadako Mari I hope
you are able to hear me and hope you're
having a wonderful weekend so I am a
research scientist at the our wildlife
here at the Koch Institute of
Integrative Cancer Research and in the
wildlife you believe that our immune
system is a powerful agent to fight
diseases different types of diseases
like cancer and autoimmune diseases and
we also believe that when cancer
develops there's a compromised function
of immune systems somehow immune system
is suppressed and that's how cancer
progresses and if we can actually clip
the immune cells or the cells immune
system to fight better with the cancer
we can actually tackle cancer eventually
so what I'm going to share with you
today is actually image which is
actually a summarized story of my
project that shows many different
subplots in a single image as to which
immune cells I'm using and how they're
interacting with the immune cells or
with the cancer cells and how what we
hope to achieve using this interaction
so I'll just briefly in a brief moment I
will share my image with you guys
yeah so basically my project started
with trying to see how the Indians are
specifically the t-cells which are my
threat immune cells because they can
directly recognize and kill cancer cells
how they interact how they communicate
how they talk to the cancer cells and
are they able to actually kill cancer
cells so I took cancer cells which are
large cells shown here there - cancer
cells here in a dish and I threw some
t-cells that would actually recognize
and kill the tumor cells and then let
them interact and it was a very
interesting interaction to watch because
I could see that these cells were
actually attacking the tumor cells and I
had already loaded the T cells with is
nanoparticles that have drug that would
increase t-cell function
they'll increase the capability to fight
these tumor cells and I could see that
the druglord t-cells were beautifully
binding to the tumor cells so they were
recognizing them and they were able to
actually kill tumor cells so in the
image that two different tumor cells the
one that is healthy and the other one
which is sort of retracting which is a
sign of it being killed by the T cells
so in this image you could actually see
different part of the processes that
entail my project which is looking at
the interaction of immune cells such as
T cells or the tumor cells as well as
seeing how drug loaded nanoparticles
could help T cells in their ability to
kill tumor cells and the idea was that
if you can actually see this process in
a dish hopefully we'll be able to
recapitulate it in the body sometime in
the models of cancer and be able to take
care of disease progression in the real
situation so with that I'd like to thank
for you for your attention and we give
it back to speak a back to Erica thank
you thank you so much Sudha what are the
things I love about this image is that
it tells a very dramatic science story
it's a very good versus evil battle
but it also is it's an image that really
comes out of the scientific process did
this experiment that we were doing
actually work
so our next image that we're going to
look at is also an image of documenting
a scientific process and it's really
looking at the experiment a little more
so I think Matt if you would like to get
your image all queued up I'll turn it
over to Matt Victor
thanks Erica just give me one second to
share my image
so my name is Matt Victor
I am a Asia my Hannah gray fellow at the
peak our Institute for learning and
memory and I have a PhD in neuroscience
but a lot of the questions I'm interest
in have to do with the developing brain
and the approach I take is that I model
neuronal development or brain
development with stem cells the field of
stem cell has really exploded in the
past decade when the discovery was made
that a fully differentiated adult cell
for example a skin cell could be
reprogrammed to become a stem cell and
that stem cell can then be made into all
known cell types in our body and that's
what we call induced fold potent stem
cells or iPS seeds so I work with IPS ES
and I differentiate the stem cells to
become neurons which are brain cells and
neurons have this amazing capacity to
generate electrical signaling and that's
how information is processed in our
brain so what I'm showing you here is an
image of nearly 20,000 neurons the cell
bodies are kind of white circles but
these cells they have a very unique
morphology where they protrude
extensions to make connections between
different cells so you can see in here
it's a droplet of 20,000 cells that have
been allowed to grow and they were
plated on a multi electrode array so
these larger black dots that are
connected wires are actually reading the
electrical potentials that the cells are
generated and I'm using the cells as a
proxy for a developing brain cell
to understand how activity shapes their
maturation so as we develop we received
a lot of input for example sensory input
like your mother's touch and all those
sensor inputs are transformed into
activity that's processed by the brain
and there is reason to think that that's
a very important part of developing a
mature brain so we're trying to mimic
that in the dish and so I think this
image is striking because it conveys a
very difficult technique which is
generating these cells from stem cells
and getting them to be functional but it
also tells you a little bit about the
interconnectivity of the cells so you
can see this meshes are connected and
some of the readouts of my research
which is to study how electrical
activity changes with maturation in
vitro so stop here and check more later
if you have more questions thank you so
much Matt yeah when Matt submitted this
to the image of our contest he also
submitted an image that was just the
neurons and it was a beautifully
striking image these glowing cell bodies
and all these interactions and data that
Matt was talking about but the judges
chose this image because they loved how
it documented the process of observing
as well and one of the things I talked
about in the opening webinar was making
comparisons across different scales of
science and so with that we're actually
going to move into another image that
also has a combination of the thing
doing the observing and the thing and
the thing being observed so Calvin Leung
is going to show his image
yeah thanks Erica um hi everyone my name
is Calvin um I am a PhD candidate and a
member of the time of our be
collaboration so as you might guess I'm
an astrophysicist and one of my biggest
science goals is to survey the night sky
for these mysterious objects called
faster radio bursts and so these are
brief bright radio flashes that are
coming from all directions towards Earth
and we think they come from outside the
Milky Way galaxy and so they're
fascinating because they're just
milliseconds long but in that one
millisecond or so that they turn on they
can sometimes keep outshine their entire
host galaxy and so this makes them
extremely powerful but super mysterious
objects to detect because they just come
and go and you never see them again so
this is a picture of the Canadian
hydrogen mapping intensity experiment or
chime and what we do is we have these
these four cylinders which are shaped
like so because they have an enormous
field of view of the sky unlike your
regular telescope which tough stairs and
tiny little patch of sky so for
reference your conventional telescope
that you might see you know on the
mountaintops of Mauna Mauna Kea or or
Palomar Observatory might have a field
of view of about 1/16 of a degree by a
sixty to the degree but with our radio
telescope with its with its metal
structure you know with these with these
cylinders which are each twenty metres
wide and 80 metres long and the weight a
point of the sky they can actually
survey a two-degree wide strip of the
entire night sky running north-south and
so we have this massive barcode scanner
on the sky that surveys of different
parts of the sky as the Earth Day Earth
rotates beneath it and so this unique
design has allowed us to discover more
fast radio bursts in a year than have
ever been detected in the past decade
and so this has really transformed the
field and so I wanted to include a
picture of not just the night sky that
were so fascinated by but also the
unique
that lets us lets us perform these
transformative observations and so
that's our the science side of this
picture that on the aesthetic side one
of the things I really liked about it is
that it conveys a strong sense of
purpose like you see these like massive
metal cylinder structures and there's
obviously some purpose to it and there
are regularity
you know gives this a sense of like
unity and harmony that I think is really
quite that really sends chills down my
spine even though I think about this
experiment every day also I'm I think on
a more personal note I mean I really
like this image is because it you know
any because I am as a scientist I'm
really interested in instrumentation and
the development of new new instruments
that can allow us to make a
transformative new science observations
like the unique design of our
cylindrical telescope and so to me every
every time you do astrophysics it's a
sort of communion between the telescope
and the night sky and so I think this is
just a particularly complete way of
expressing that it's not just the sky
but it's also what you use to look at it
and so income you know in summary those
three things sort of the the science
appeal the the the sense of grandeur
that you get and also that that sort of
personal touch make you know make me
have this feeling that something
something magical is really going on
here yes that's why I showed this photo
um before I finish I want to just
mention that I actually did not take
this this was taken by one of my very
close collaborators Andre Renard at the
University of Toronto that's all I've
got
I'll pass it back to Eric Adel thank you
thank you so much yeah one of the things
I think is really interesting so it's a
photo and feature it's a photo of
technology but somehow when you put all
those things together it's also a very
human photo about our own mission to
understand the world and to learn more
about the world and create things that
help us appreciate what's going on in
nature so with that I think we're gonna
shift gears to a different engineer some
different engineered cylinders we're
gonna head back to the biological scale
and look at the image of of something
that that we built to not just
understand how the body works but also
to improve how the body works
Quintin Smith is our next presenter all
right good afternoon everyone and thank
you so much for joining I'm today
my name is Quintin Smith I'm a
postdoctoral fellow at MIT Cooke
Institute and I work under the
mentorship or Sangeeta Bhatia is
laboratory for multi scale regenerative
technologies so the particular research
lens that I'm focused in is liver tissue
engineering so the liver is what one of
the coolest organs it actually has a
unique ability to regenerate you can
actually remove two-thirds of the liver
and it will completely regrow
so we've actually taken advantage of
that unique property for people who
actually need liver transplants for
survival so you can do something called
a split liver transplant or you can take
a liver from one person and put it in
another and it can actually grow back on
both of the patients so one of the big
difficulties with in this field is that
there is over 114 thousand people in the
United States that are in need of this
life-saving surgery so there's not
enough donors to support this demand so
I'm actually a chemical engineer by
training so you kind of think about how
can we create engineering solutions
Shirley bridge the gap between the
unavailability of these organ systems
sewing this word here and this image
here I want to demonstrate one
particular architecture within the liver
as a way to create mini miniature livers
in the lab that we can actually implant
for patients so there's like kind of a
lot of different intricacies that were
done to really create this picture so
what I'm showing here is an image of
something called a biliary duct so this
is a very important component within the
liver that's actually responsible for
curing bile acid from the liver to the
small intestines where it actually helps
in aids aids in digestion so people who
have liver problems for example they
actually get something called jaundice
where you have yellowing of the eyes or
yellowing of the skin and nails and this
is actually that bile acid leaking out
so we understand this biliary
architecture is very important so what
I'm showing in this image here are cells
that make up the bile duct where we can
control their architecture in a very
specific manner so this open structure
that we can create is actually on the
order of a human hair size so these are
around 150 to 300 microns in diameter
and how we do it we'd use a pretty cool
technique we use acupuncture needles and
we cast a biologically relevant material
in which cells thrive in and use the
acupuncture needles as a sacrificial
mold after we create this mold with the
extracellular matrix that builds up
tissues we can remove this really small
needle and we're open with pur fusible
systems where we can seed with these
biliary epithelial cells so what I
really like about this image is that we
can you can see that as engineers that
we can recapitulate the architecture
that we see in biology so here's a proof
of concept where we can create these
very two standing structures that mimic
the architecture of the liver itself so
I really like this picture and I hope
you guys do and I'm really excited for
the Q&A session afterwards and with that
I'll get a vodka Erica thank you
Thank You Quentin yeah I actually
learned about unlike many of the Image
Awards entries I learned about this
project where I saw the image and I made
Quentin draw me lots of pictures of how
it all worked and then seeing this image
just really Illustrated you know how
important the photography was for
understanding these sorts of things so
our final image today is actually not an
image that was taken through research
but is really an image taken of research
so Lina Lina Kohler just goes there the
final image before we move into Q&A hi
everyone my name is Lena Colucci I have
a PhD from MIT and Harvard Medical
School I
wrap that up a couple years ago and
since then I actually co-founded a
boutique data science consulting company
called edge enna lytx we're out in the
bay area and basically companies bring
us in to help us solve they're really
difficult to machine learning challenges
we work with big fortune 500 companies
we work with some of Silicon Valley's
top startups and we're with them from
early prototyping of potential solutions
de-risking all the way to ultimately
building and shipping the best ones and
the photo that I'm going to share with
you today is one that has a really
interesting backstory so this is um I'm
gonna get into exactly what you're
looking at in a second but essentially
one of my lab mates at MIT asked me to
help her photograph her PhD research and
she works on novel cancer treatments and
essentially she developed these
materials that are filled with cancer
treating drugs in them and essentially
you implant these materials into the
body and they slowly release these
cancer treating drugs and provide the
person's chemotherapy in a long-term way
the goal however is that you want to
insert these implants to treat someone's
cancer in a minimal type of surgery as
possible so you don't want to have a big
surgery so she came up with the idea of
creating these implants and folding them
like origami so that um this material
can fold up really small and through
something called a laparoscopic surgery
and you can insert this material they're
very tiny incision but then once it's
actually inside the body the material
opens up and can spread through a larger
of the body and treat a big area of the
body in this case it would be the
abdomen so once you came and asked me to
help her photograph these implants
um it was a little bit challenging
because the ink lines are white or
transparent so they don't necessarily
photograph well so the interesting
backstory is we came up with the idea
actually using origami paper itself and
then playing around with lights to kind
of help create these interesting shadows
and coloring effects of these implants
so here you can see some of the behind
the scenes photos that we took I'm in
creating this image so playing around
with squeezing the implants different
shapes lighting origami paper in the
background and what you can see is the
different variety and types of images
that we were able to take through these
techniques and this is interesting video
we took at the end that really kind of
shows the beauty of these origami folds
and really the clever part of her work
is using this really ancient art form of
origami to a new type of cancer
treatment something that can help people
in the modern world today so with that I
will pass it back to Erica Thank You
Lina yeah we wanted to close with close
the sharing with that in part because
Lina did such a great job of explaining
kind of the choices that she made in
taking these images and even though this
was kind of a macroscale device I think
all the images that we are looking at
today there were choices made in how to
set it up and present it and that ties
really nicely into this first question
that we've gotten on the Q&A so again
I'm going to remind everybody that the
Q&A window is open so please submit your
photos whether for your questions sorry
for an individual or the group but we're
gonna bring everybody back on screen now
and our anonymous attendee would like to
know oh and let me note that this
presentation is being recorded you
probably saw it at the top of your
screen but we are recording it and we'll
be posting this online with the other
Imaging Science tutorials and the
opening webinar but the question on
screen here is what advice would you
give to other researchers or people
trying out science photography about how
to make their images more compelling and
anyone can take it we're gonna try the
free-for-all and see how it goes
so I think one important thing just was
scientific imaging is there are a lot of
different tools that you can use but I
really think the narrative behind the
stories really brings it home so just
from the other panelists I was very
impressed about your storytelling
abilities and I think really having that
background on that story
really elevates the meaning of those
pictures so for me for example when I
show my friends pictures of cells
they're like I don't understand what
this is but when you put it when you
contextualize it I think that really
elevates the importance of the picture I
will add my own thoughts on it but one
of my advisors at some point told me
that I was trying to make my images too
pretty and I think kind of appreciating
the inherit poise and complexity and
maybe ugly parts of biology and by
Oakley I just mean not uniform not you
know so tight kind of appreciating that
that's there's beauty in that as well I
think that goes a long way
I guess I'll just add some thoughts from
from purely you know a photographic
perspective I totally agree with the
narrative and the what Quentin and Matt
have said from purely photographic
perspective it only helps to have a
really high-quality photo right so what
that means is things in focus really
nice composition lighting crops like
that having a beautiful you know doesn't
have to be beautiful in the nice-looking
leave but a nicely composed photo and
with good technique is what's gonna make
someone pause and be like oh wow that's
really interesting what is that I'm so
good photographic technique really helps
excellent thank you we have somebody who
would love to hear from you about how
the process of imaging your science has
helped shape your thinking about your
research I could take this one um so I
guess every time I I try to think of an
of
you know a research project or something
I try to think about how I will you know
how I how how my project makes sense
in terms of like or or rather like what
is the context of the project in the
broader in the broader world and so
every time I do something I think about
like why people should care about this
and how I can present these results to
the world and convince people that
they're significant and I think that's
actually a really helpful process
because as researchers you know you know
we like go and read many papers and then
we say oh well there are like you know a
hundred you know questions that seem
interesting but when you like to sort of
zoom out for a bit and think about how
you're gonna convey that to the world I
think it's a really good exercise in
learning how to triage your priorities
because oftentimes when limited not by
like what we can do but will we have the
time and where we want best want to
spend our effort doing so at least one
way that the the process of not just
imaging but also communicating my ideas
is guides where literally what I spend
my days doing
can I add a few words to what Calvin had
to say actually I completely agree with
him so my research actually largely
imaging things as they're happening so
message relies a lot on basically
evidence gathering through looking at
pictures and basically the part and
parcel of the whole
sort of imaging techniques is that basis
of accuracy in what you are imaging and
it actually tells you a lot about what
to do next
so I often would have liked tool parts
that I put into a system and then image
how they are coming together to in fact
even know what could be the story and
what to do next to even explore this
story further so amazing is a very
powerful tool of the scientific process
and it can tell you a lot on day to day
basis and this might just generally
involve that yeah so it can definitely
change your scientific spiration to a
great extent yeah so basically it is a
way powerful tool and very powerful
influencer in my research areas
we have a question from Rachel how much
do you think about your photos in the
layout do you plan it out I no tsuita
you just said you take pictures of
things as they happen but how about
everybody do you do you plan it out or
do you take a bunch of image and test a
lot of things until you find an image
that works for you so kind of just in my
approach with science we actually try to
take as many pictures as you can I'm
looking at biological phenomenon as Matt
was discussing there's a lot of noise
and a lot of background so you really
want to try to capture as many events as
you can possibly really dictating that
phenomenon that you're trying to
describe or observe but then sometimes
you have very unique things that pop out
from those mosaic of images that you
take but generally in my approach I try
to take as many different types of
pictures to really capture the
phenomenon that I'm studying I think for
me a lot of times I'm thinking about the
magnification in which I'm taking the
picture sometimes you know we want to
get really close to individual cell but
then sometimes we kind of want to take a
step back and take a larger image which
might require like composite of many
images to be taken so and those for
example the image I took probably took a
couple hours to be able to acquire so I
think a lot of times I play around with
setting up this kind of like composite
or individual and seeing what looks good
I do have to say that all my images I
tend to think about they're gonna be
shown or seen as like a foam size these
are gonna be small little panels in like
a much larger data rich hopefully figure
but the idea I sometimes the higher
magnification is a little easier to show
in a small insect
great anyone else okay so we have a
question from Jodi here so obviously
we're all taking these pictures cuz we
love science and we're doing science and
how important is the imaging when you're
trying to get new funding or applying
for a new project what roles are those
images play
so typically when we are trying to get
new funding we have to write grants and
grants typically include preliminary
data and I think having a good image
won't necessarily you know get you those
dollar bills but it certainly the
comments I've gotten from reviewers is
that they would say this is really
high-quality preliminary data and I
think part of that lingo is about just
the striking this of the images but
together with a lot more quantification
and the story as a whole it's not solely
based on the image but I think it goes a
long way
did anyone want to add to that great
just one kind of minor no sometimes I
really like the sentiment that seeing is
believing right so it really just drives
your point home like at least the type
of work that I demonstrated really
seeing the nice oriented structures is a
really nice proof of concept to really
drag some of your ideas home so if you
can even capture it in like a schematic
for example just like the imagery and
demonstrating really the validity of
your your proposal is really important
and then Sudha did I see they actually I
was gonna say what Canton just said that
I totally agree with you that part of
the scientific mazing goals so evidence
gathering so an image is also piece of
really powerful evidence and it can
demonstrate that you are you are able to
basically capture the process to some
extent for which you're asking money
already so it's a it's also a piece of
evidence and seeing is believing so yeah
it helps yeah terrific
all right we have a few more questions
here but what I want to do is actually
move on to look at some of the images
that were taken through imaging science
so if and we'll have some time for Q&A
after as well so we've asked every one
of these five fabulous people to pick an
image out of the gorgeous array that was
submitted some of you saw those in the
opening slide show but we've asked
everybody to pick an image and we're
gonna just have a conversation about
some of the images that stood out to
people and what they liked about them
and we're going to mix up the order this
time I think Calvin why don't we start
with you
sounds good thanks Erica um so I I
really like this photo of a pot of water
on a stove and I actually really stood
out to me not because the subject was
particularly unusual like everyone boils
a pot of water every day but I think
this is a really indicative of the
scientific process in physics and
astronomy where a lot of the times there
are processes that you want to observe
and you don't have direct access to that
so if you want to see fire you look at
the pot of boiling water that's on top
of it I think that's really the image
here right you don't like we all
intuitively can make that scientific
leap you know even without seeing the
flames or without feeling the heat you
look at this pot of water you look at
the way that bubbles are formed these
are very different from soap bubbles and
you already know that there's like you
know there's a phase transition between
the liquid and the gas phases of the
water and that's probably caused by
convection from below and there's a heat
source underneath that and that's why we
include that at the bottom of this at
the bottom of this pot there is there is
there is a gas fire making making these
bubbles and so you know we proved the
existence of fire every day just by
looking at this image and I think that's
pretty cool I love that the story within
the story do any of our other presenters
want to comment on this photo or what
Calvin said not everybody has seen each
of the photos that everyone's picked
yeah I really loved this photo as well
I'm so glad you picked it Calvin
um for me what was really striking is
when you first look at it you're like
what is it and then you know you take a
couple seconds and you're like oh yeah
this is boiling water and for me that
you know that instant of like some
really interesting visual that makes you
pause and say what am I looking at um
like that instant especially in a
science photograph is that opportunity
to teach and learn right because then
someone's going to look at the title or
caption and learn something and this
Calvin has expanded upon it's an
opportunity to teach you know about
phase shifts or
you know different phases of water and
boiling whatever the the direction the
photographer wants to take the teaching
in its this photograph is just an
invitation for that alright well now
we're cooking sounds good I think
Quinton I think you're up next then so I
might be a little biased in this picture
I'm from New Mexico so immediately the
cacti Spike's like a Matsuri well really
what I really enjoy about this picture
is just that the complexity in terms of
the organization in the architecture so
you see a lot of order you see the
spikes in a very particular manner and
with the image that cost the the purple
backdrop it really highlights the
different but different cacti so I
really enjoyed this image not only from
me kind of being a little homesick and
reminding me of New Mexico but also
being able to capture the different
architectures with them that I just
wanted to add that there's so many
beautiful images of nature it seemed
that a lot of people are very inspired
by being outdoors and I think especially
when we're experiencing a lot of you
know being walked up but I agree this is
great yes one thing that I didn't have
time to talk about in the opening
webinar and I'm gonna kind of jump in
and hijack this a little bit and talk
about my own graduate work in
understanding how people make sense of
images is what I did with my graduate
work as I looked at how people make
sense of science imagery using an arts
education framework and so one of the
frameworks I used was the tape modern
ways of looking which says that we look
at images in a variety of ways and
artwork in a variety of ways and the
first thing we do is find that personal
connection and I I heard that from from
Quinton there and then after that we
want to know we want to look at the
subject and say well what is this a
picture of what's what's going on here
what's happening which is of course a
key element of science but then even
beyond that people want to look at the
object at the photograph or the artwork
or the the composition as something that
was deliberately created what did you
use to take this what
why did you choose these colors what's
going on what's what are the physical
properties of the image itself and then
the fourth way of looking is just
looking at this wider context why did we
take this image what was going on in the
world when this photograph was taken and
I think that's something that really
comes out in all of these photos
all right Lina would you like to share
an image with us sure let me share my
screen all right so I've touched on this
before but what I really love about
photographing especially science
photographs is a photo that makes you
pause for some reason it could be like
that it's just a beautiful image it
could be that you kind of do a
double-take you like what am I looking
at and then once you have that hook that
someone's caused in the midst of their
busy day that's an opportunity to go and
teach something and the reason I love
this photo and I guess I'll say before
before I dive into this one in
particular um there were so many
fantastic photos anyone who submitted a
photo should be incredibly proud there
were so many really good ones
I ultimately picked this one a because I
thought it was so beautiful the colors
are stunning the composition is stunning
it's this really ethereal quality of a
photo and then so it just made me pause
and again then that's an opportunity to
go and teach something so I feel like
the once you have someone's attention
here it's an opportunity to teach about
surface tension or ripple patterns and
wave formations and equations for the
you know crest and trough of waves so
there's a lot that kind of can be taught
once you have that person's attention so
one thing that I really like about this
image is that it freezes the motion
which is a very hard thing to do
technically and also it's very beautiful
to look at first like a draw up that's
basically is frozen in time and those
image is actually very powerful because
they're telling the story in time but in
one frame those beautifully captured
phenomena and happened
that's the sort of nice feature of this
image I really like yes hey Calvin why
don't you go ahead now one neat detail I
notice is that you'll notice that around
the droplet there are these two rings of
water propagating outwards and the fact
that the outer ring is much more is much
more smeared out than the inner one
tells you that the speed of surface
waves on this water is different for
different for different wavelengths so
that's a pretty pretty non-trivial
pretty non-trivial thing to notice just
in this pictures there's a lot of very
interesting detail captured here
terrific thanks yes I love the capturing
of time and space in these things and
both of those things are essential for
for running a science experiment or
what's happening in our world time and
space matter all right but Matt let's
let's see your your choice
I take the field but this one really
spoke to me because I have this moto in
lab that everything is data so I carry
my iPhone with me everywhere and iPhone
cameras are so good nowadays that I kind
of do this a lot where I put my camera
onto the ocular of the microscope and so
you end up getting this kind of ring
which is the ocular but then you get the
image through and I typically will crop
it you know and just use the image
inside but I love the fact that this
tells a very clear message at least to
me as a scientist of where that
photographer was I feel like I
understand the process i I'm seeing it
as a person saw it and you know there
were there were a series of images
posted with the same kind of photograph
from a microscope was just different
maybe substrates being imaged but I I
think that when you can capture the the
process in the image I think that could
be really powerful too so this is kind
of what spoke to me about the series of
phone to the ocular images I have a
comment on that it's a great choice Matt
I also like the part that the texture of
the subject is so nicely visible in the
image which is not usually the case
normally the compromise between contrast
in texture and here that doesn't seem to
be the case so it's really commendable
effort on technicality and it's a really
great a page yeah I think that
comparison can be really powerful an
image one of the things we talked about
with Keith Keith and felices making the
decision of what to photograph and what
not to photograph and what you show is
often dependent on what you don't show
or the choices you make of how you
compare things absolutely alright
Suda is your is your image ready to go
there it is so apologies for the
interruption and so I I like a surveys
because like Lina was saying that I'm
interesting aspect to the images that it
may if it will incite you to stop and
pause for a moment and think a little
bit about the image maybe the process of
how it was taken the story around it and
also a message that is coming through
and I felt that this image was combining
a lot of different things and these
different things are nicely so first of
all the composition is really nice the
objects the ice creams are nicely placed
and even though they're they are
brilliant in color the colors are very
nice and and overall composition is very
very nice but I also liked about is also
my personal bias as a microscopy person
so I like to see small things seen in
better details to see things that we
can't generally see with the naked eye
or ordinarily so to see beyond what our
eye eyes can see so for example if I
hold my screen I would know that's
actually asymmetrical so then one side
is more shaded than the other side
something asymmetry I didn't know
existed and then what if this dark color
is it where the embryo used to sit or
the the fertile part of the right screen
which again I didn't know existed in a
in a processed rice like this so it's
like a like a collection of scientific
messages that are encompassing this
image so at that part I really liked I
also liked technical mystery around it
so I really want to know how it was
taken there seems to be some back
lumination happening
but I'm not sure so it seems like the
puzzle to the image had a good sense of
technicality of how to illuminate is
Graeme's to get the most information out
so I really like that part yeah so
basically it's a combination of the
composition the visualization beyond
what will ordinarily see and also the
trick that has been used here that's why
I really like this image
thank you would any of the other
panelists like to comment on this image
yeah it's gonna ask what the little dark
flecks are there are these big dark dark
spots as you said I think at the embryos
of the rice screen but there are also
sort of these dark flecks and I don't do
you have any idea what those are or are
those just like imperfections
I don't think about plants so same yeah
I don't have here what I can see them
it's an interesting question maybe the
participant could comment on it later or
any of you know about it I don't know it
adds nice features to the the graves but
I'm not sure if I'm not mistaken this
image was posted on social media which
means it's there on the hashtag and
perhaps that's a nice conversation to
begin online I love this idea of we
didn't really talk about this but it was
so important that a good image provokes
questions and in some cases we've seen
those or questions about the details of
what's being photographed about the
wider context and phenomenon that's
behind it looking for things we can't
see and you know like clearly you all
are scientists because you you've got
questions about these and the photos
both answer them and ask them as well
and I think that's really powerful I was
just going to jump in to say that one of
our attendees Dora bevor is telling us
this these are the germs of the germ of
the right case and this is the part that
will become the plate so maybe this is
her image or she's a rice enthusiast yes
I think this is Dora's image excellent I
can't see the chat I'm I'm making sure
my microphone is is on and off but I can
see the clock and I see that we are
almost at two o'clock and I think any
all of us could go on and on and talk
about what we love about images there
are a couple questions about what you
use to take your photos what what tools
you like for photography do you use your
camera phone if you wanted to type in
answers to that while Brian talks
a little bit more about where we want to
go from here this was a two-week
experiment with with imaging science
before I turn it over to Brian I do want
to thank all of our researchers thank
you so much for taking time out of your
Saturday afternoons or mornings for
those of you in California to share your
images your perspectives
I love the conversation that we had and
the different perspectives on both the
research images and the MIT imaging
science images and I'm so grateful for
all of you for joining in the last
question is you know what are the
opportunities for students who want to
continue pursuing imaging science and so
for that we're obviously going to leave
this content online but I think I'll
bring Brian back to kind of answer the
questions about where where things are
going from here Thank You Erica thank
you everyone all of our panelists for
joining us today and thank you to all
the participants out there who have
submitted some really incredible photos
I think you did exactly what we were
hoping which was get out there go around
your homes go outside and take some cool
images make some observations of things
that you hadn't before through
photography
so this is our closing webinar for this
section of imaging science but please
keep a lookout for more programming
under the title imaging science or under
the hashtag MIT TM Imaging Science
because we definitely like to continue
doing things with imaging and imaging
science photography and science into the
future so we're gonna sign off now but
I'm going to throw up the slideshow of
many of the images that have been
submitted throughout the two weeks so
feel free to hang on for a few minutes
and enjoy those images as they come in
yeah thank you to everyone to submitted
images and thank you again to our
panelists for for helping us appreciate
what makes great science photos thanks
Erica and Bryan for putting everything
together I'm sticking
because I'm excited to to see all these
images cuz I I told myself I was going
to be surprised when they came on the
slideshow but thank you everybody
you